hi there
maybe you can hear in the background
jerry and the pacemakers sing singing
you will never walk alone
which is sort of the the
theme song of the liverpool soccer fans
in england
and i think if we learn languages it's
the same we'll never walk alone
let me just turn him off
but you know it can sometimes seem as if
learning a language is a lonely task you
of course you listen on your own you
read on your own
uh
but there are many ways in which it can
be something that connects you with
other people obviously if you have an
online tutor i just finished having a
conversation with my arabic tutor this
morning
and i spent the weekend
listening doing a lot of listening i
listened five hours on saturday did a
lot of reading and linking and i really
felt
that my
my arabic had improved and i was able to
show that to my tutor
uh
this morning and so i'm connecting i'm
connecting with the content that i
listen to i'm connecting with my tutor
and i know that i'm developing the
ability to connect even more in the
future both with the language and the
culture and with people that i'll be
able to communicate with in the language
and as you learn
there are so many things that you can do
to to sort of
reach out to other members of the
language learning community
uh obviously to connect with the tutor
uh getting getting on our forum
either asking questions or answering
questions about the language you're
learning or your native language
i also think that it's very useful to to
review your statistics maybe in the
community you have the ability to
compare yourself with others
i recently
on one of my language workouts
was asked to review the profile
of several of our members at link and
what was common to all of them was that
they don't listen enough
you should look at what other people are
doing and if you're not listening enough
listen more listen hours and hours get
the language in you it's connecting you
to the language
uh
use your playlists a lot of people don't
use the playlist
save your lessons to a playlist so that
you can carry that with you you're not
walking alone when i walk i listen i'm
connecting to
hopefully content that i find
interesting the content that i'm
listening to now in arabic
even though i don't fully understand it
but after reading it and saving words i
do start to understand it and these are
political podcast discussions with
people their lives and all of this is
enabling me to connect so that i'm not
walking alone
i think part of the the risk let's say
of online language learning is that you
feel that uh you know you're not uh
you know you're not connected how well
am i doing and that's where the
statistics can even if you don't feel
you're improving if you are
you know
totaling up those listening hours those
reading words those links
you are learning and if you can connect
with a tutor so much the better you
don't have to do it every day for hours
even
once a week right now i'm doing
basically two hours a week you're
connecting so it's important
to uh realize that
learning another language is a
tremendously social thing to do
even if you don't have the opportunity
all the time to speak the language
you can listen
uh
you know i mentioned the tutor i get the
tutor's report i can review
uh discussions that i had with my tutor
six months ago again i'm connecting so
language learning is not
even though many of the activities are
solitary activities you have to read on
your own you have to listen on your own
but those are activities that connect
you to people connect you to the
language to native speakers and even to
other learners so i just wanted to make
the point that you're not on your own
we can even put this guy back on
so we don't walk alone
when we learn a language
you're doing something profoundly
social
thank you
and good luck in your ongoing journey